We have to be stewards of our
environment, we have to be able
to protect the rich biodiversity
that's on our planet because we
benefit from that. Scientific
research is critical because
that gives us the information we
need to really understand what
it is we need to put our
resources into protecting. My
name is Tracy Seimon. I'm the
director of the Wildlife
Conservation Society's molecular
lab based at the Bronx Zoo.  We
do a lot of diagnostic testing
to screen animals that are in
our collection. We do PCR to
monitor for a lot of different
pathogens. We also help
develop portable technologies
that we can take into the field
and really empower our
researchers around the world to
be able to do diagnostic testing
on the spot. My career
trajectory has taken a very
circuitous path. Because I was
really interested in studying
disease and mechanisms of
disease, and particularly at the
time I really thought I was
gonna go into cancer research.
On the side I started studying
amphibians. And this was because
I had met Anton Seimon. He's a
climate scientist, who's now my
husband. And he was leading
expeditions down to Peru to
understand how climate change is
impacting high mountain
environments. And so on one of
their expeditions, they were
speaking to the local
communities, the Quechua
communities, who informed them
that they had been seeing a lot
of frog die offs. Anton knew I
worked in a experimental
pathology program and reached
out to me. And so that's how I
came aboard the project. I love
high mountain environments. This
is an area that I've invested
research in over two decades
now. We've been doing continuous
monitoring of amphibians up in
the upper reaches of the Andean
ecosystem. This is probably the
highest herpetological site up
here. It's at 17,000 feet. What we're
collecting is Pleurodema
marmoratum. Amphibians they're
basically indicator species that
tell us a lot about how the
environment is changing. What
we're doing is is swabbing these
frogs to test for amphibian chytrid fungus.
We first found amphibian chytrid fungus here in 2003.
So as the glaciers are receding, you're
getting new ponds that are
forming higher and higher up.
When these new ponds form that
creates the environment to where
pollens get deposited up there,
and microbes, And that starts
building the soils. And then
those soils can start allowing
growth of plants, which then
bring up insects. And so the
whole biosphere is actually
rising in response to the rising
global temperatures.
We also have research part of the lab
where we take on projects with
collaborators. Some of that
diagnostic support has been
through developing eDNA tests.
eDNA stands for environmental
DNA. And it is DNA that's shed
from organisms that exist in an
environment. Its DNA that can be
captured through, for example,
water samples, soil samples, and
even air samples.
And it's a powerful tool that allows
conservationists to search for
rare and threatened species, and
look for evidence of specific
species, you can use it to
perform biodiversity assessments
to look at all the organisms in
the environment.
Our first area where we've opened the door to
eDNA analysis for biodiversity
assessment was actually done on
Mount Everest in 2019. So the
expedition actually was very
interdisciplinary, pulled
scientists from all all over the
world. And so they needed some
biologists. So our idea was to
do basically collect water
samples along an elevational
gradient up to the highest
ponds. When we were camping on
on the glacier at Everest base
camp, we were sleeping on a
moving glacier. And the sound of
the crackling of the glacier
beneath your tent as you're
falling asleep and the
thunderous roars of the
avalanche is coming down. It's
both scary, but at the same
time, it's, it's just amazing to
hear it.
From these 10 sites that we identified, we collected
over 20 liters of water. When we
brought that back to the lab, we
performed analysis of the eDNA
that we captured from the
filters from those 20 liters of
water. And we performed whole
genome shotgun sequencing, so we
sequenced everything. But we
also performed DNA
meta barcoding, where we targeted
what you call a DNA barcoding
gene, which is a mitochondrial
DNA target, to then identify
organisms, often down to the
species level. Out of this
analysis we identified 187
taxonomic orders from 36 phylum,
which is quite impressive. It's
across the entire tree of life.
So we identified everything from
a few viruses, bacteria, fungi,
plants, animals. When you put
into context, the number of
taxonomic orders that we
recovered from these 20 liters
of water. When we compare them
to total known taxonomic orders
of around the world, we
discovered basically 1/6 of
global taxonomic orders just on
this one mountain above 4500
meters. Which is quite
remarkable, especially when you
think about areas around the
earth above 4500 meters occupies
only about 3% of landmass. It
was quite striking that we found
that that level of diversity up
on the high slopes of Everest.
I mean, we're really pushing the
boundaries with trying to detect
eDNA. And one of our projects,
where we're focused on trying to
detect this very rare turtle
species in Vietnam called
Rafetus swinhoei which is the
Yangtze giant softshell turtle.
Our researchers can go out and
systematically test lakes and
rivers for the presence of this
species. And it's really
critical that we find additional
individuals in order to save the
species from going extinct
because they're they're really
on the verge of blinking out. As
stewards of the earth we need to
be able to ensure that
generations to come  benefit
from the rich biodiversity on
our planet.